What's up guys? Wait a minute you guys aren't the real Avengers. I can tell Hulk gives it away
That Was Awesome
Did Liz get a new top ? No you've seen that before
Never with that skirt. Should probably stop staring before it gets creepy though
Yeah
Too late
You guys are losers
So to become an avenger are there like trials or an interview?
Just don't do anything I would do and definitely don't do anything I wouldn't do
There's a little gray area in there, and that's where you operate. Oh alright. That's not a hug
I'm just grabbing the door for you all right kid. Good luck out there
Listen I know school sucks. Peter you still with us? Uhh...yeah yeah. I know you want to save the world
But,
You're not ready yet
You are the Spiderman
No I'm not , I'm not
This is just a costume, this's
You're on the ceiling !
Stay close to the ground
And stay outta trouble
Forget the flying monster guy there are people who handle this sort of things
I'm sick of him treating me like a kid all the time. But, you are a kid
This is my chance To prove my self
Peter, What is going on with you
I'm really I'm so busy I'm slam
Don't mess with me, cause I'll kill you and everybody you loved